[Musique]
vendredi 14 heures c'est la fin de la
grande prière à banda aceh au nord de
l'indonésie dans un instant solna va
être battu devant près de mille
personnes
son crime avoir passé la nuit avec son
petit ami
deux ans après le tsunami les châtiments
en public réapparaissent après plus d'un
siècle d'absence à banda aceh
ici les traces de la catastrophe sont
encore visibles un peu partout dans la
ville
mais lorsque l'eau s'est retirée en
janvier 2005 une autre vague s'est
abattue sur atx et avec l'accord du
gouvernement
on les appelle les chemises vertes
trente hommes et 15 femmes
ils forment la police religieuse avis à
la population tous les couples non
mariés doivent quitter la plage
immédiatement jeune homme jeune fille
vous n'avez pas le droit de rester
ensemble mais là il ya beaucoup de monde
vous n'avez pas le droit de vous
afficher en public
on va les encercler vous parle à moi par
ici nous sommes lancés par une
catastrophe cela ne vous suffit pas
souvenez vous que la ville de banda aceh
a été anéantie par le tsunami
plus vos péchés se rendre en plus les
catastrophes seront grandes
bonjour vous êtes mari et femme non ça
se voit vous avez un comportement trop
affectueux l'un envers l'autre
il faut que vous vous sépariez allait
rentrer chez vous tout de suite mais on
était juste assis il ya trop de gens qui
peuvent vous voir à les rentrer vous
préviens arrêtez de vous comporter avec
une telle négligence et éviter ces
attitudes subversive en public
pensez au salut des autres votre
attitude peut anéantir toute la
population et dax il écoute qui traînent
ici aller faut y aller là
allez s'il reste ensemble trop longtemps
ils risquent de faire l'amour est cent
alors notre devoir c'est de les séparer
on fait ça pour les protéger les
chemises vertes date chez agissent
uniquement sur dénonciation et north
mission se veut éducative annonce par
mégaphone campagne d'affichage en ville
également en brochure qui met en garde
contre les principaux pêcher le flirt le
jeu et l'alcool
[Musique]
ils possèdent leurs propres locaux leur
propre uniforme
ici les policiers de dieu se relaient 24
heures sur 24 salariés du ministère des
affaires religieuses ils ont entre 20 et
35 ans ils ont tous reçu une formation
universitaire traduira dan est un homme
heureux
c'est lui qui a mis en place cette
police de la fois je ne veux pas que mes
policiers des armes
ainsi notre seule arme c'est la
persuasion je suis allé à la mecque j'ai
pu constater contre nous et les pays
arabes
il y a une grande différence là bas les
gens sont têtus ils ont le sang chaud
nous ont donc une police sans pitié atx
et on est durs aussi mais pas autant que
depuis le tsunami le tribunal islamique
de banda aceh a pris le pas sur la
justice civile
ici le code pénal ne s'applique pas seul
le coran
doubt salem et juge au tribunal
islamique
quelle que soit la punition qu'il
s'agisse de flagellation ou d'amputation
de la main il faut que cela soit validée
par le gouvernement avant de pouvoir
être appliquée ici le gouvernement a
accepté la flagellation avec une canne
en bambou et c'est une bonne chose pour
nous mais pour frapper les coupables
avec une boule à pic de fer ou pour
pouvoir leur imputer la main on doit
encore attendre un peu et quelques
mètres plus loin dans l'enceinte du
ministère de la justice religieuse un
cours un peu particulier se prépare ça
crie ça prêt à donner sa leçon il est
prof pour bourreau et comprenait bien
l'objectif n'est pas de tuer est un nid
de faire saigner
vous devez juste faire un petit
mouvement un peu comme un réflexe
vous ne devez pas prendre de l'élan
voyez comme ça le coût serait trop
violent
nous on plie le bras ont frappé en
revient on plie on frappe et origine il
est minuit la police religieuse est de
retour dans la rue ils traquent les
potentiels candidats au coût de bateaux
à banda aceh
il n'y a ni boîte de nuit ni barney
cinéma alors quand la police intervient
la jeunesse est un peu au spectacle
oui la fille
[Musique]
mais sort de la sors de là qu'est ce que
tu fais ici
d'apparence alimente dans le camion on
t'embarque vous assistez souvent à des
arrestations
oui oui souvent très souvent
voilà récemment ils ont arrêté un
aveugle qui couchait avec un travesti
c'est vrai c'est vrai est ce que les
choses se sont améliorées à aceh depuis
qu'il y à cette police religieuse non
depuis qu' à cette police religieuse
c'est de pire en pire
tous ces en cachette un avis partagé
lors d'un récent sondage 80% des
personnes interrogées disaient ne pas
être satisfaite de la manière dont la
loi coranique est appliquée à aceh
écouter les filles vous risquez toutes
les deux la flagellation
premièrement vous ne portez pas de voile
et en plus vous traîner le soir avec des
hommes et ça ça peut vous conduire à la
fornication musulmane alors n'oubliez
pas vos désirs sont vos pires ennemis
les désirs même taux diable ce soir vous
avez suivi vos désirs pour vous c'est
déjà trop tard
vous êtes sous l'emprise du démentent la
leçon de morale va durer ainsi près de
deux heures et ce soir les filles s'en
sortent plutôt bien pour toute punition
seule l'obligation de participer à trois
demi journées d'éducation religieuse
samedi jour de shabbat à jérusalem ici
pas question de sexe ni de bonheur
conjugal non ceux qui agitent les
quelques centaines de juifs ultra
orthodoxes qui manifestent en plein
centre ville
c'est l'ouverture d'un parking municipal
et ce malgré l'interdît religieux qui
impose de ne pas travailler ni de
conduire pendant le shabbat
[Musique]
la ville et sainte pas question de
transgresser les commandements de dieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour les plus radicaux la télévision est
interdite elle aussi
[Applaudissements]
en marge quelques contres manifestants
drapeaux israéliens la main une maigre
opposition face à la vague ultra
orthodoxes ces gens là veulent se
débarrasser de tous les laïcs et que la
ville ne soient peuplés que d'ultra
orthodoxes
ils veulent nous chasser on se laissera
pas faire la police repousse les
manifestants jusqu'à mea sharim le fief
des ultra orthodoxes un quartier
totalement cacher en plein centre de
jérusalem où vivent retranchés
quinze mille hommes en noir ici ce sont
les habitants qui dicte les lois selon
les principes les plus strictes de la
religion
tenue correcte exigée à l'entrée pas de
jute qu i de pantalons pour les femmes à
de télévision ni même de journaux jugés
opposé à la fois et bien sûr pas de
voiture le jour du shabbat
ils ont même imposer cela non mixité
dans les bus où l'on ne peut filmer en
caméra cachée les hommes à l'avant les
femmes à l'arrière
johann kraus enea mea sharim il est la
mémoire du quartier chez lui des
souvenirs de tous les combats menés la
marque de leur lutte contre le monde
extérieur là il y a un souvenir de notre
combat pour les bus non mixtes dans
notre quartier
bien sûr il reste des lignes non casher
qui passe par chez nous la ville a voulu
en rajouter mais elle a dû en abandonner
l'idée de toute façon ce n'est pas très
important dans deux ans tous les laïcs
auront quitté ses rangs
des ultraorthodoxes littéralement en
guerre contre les laïcs et ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux à jérusalem près
de la moitié de la population
pourtant c'est en profitant des
divisions entre les hommes en noir qu'un
non religieux nir barkat a été élu maire
depuis ses ennemis lui mènent la vie
dure
ils lui reprochent l'ouverture du
parking pendant le shabbat même
lorsqu'il a rendez vous avec les
entrepreneurs
il y a toujours un barbu pour le
sermonner monsieur le maire voici un
cadeau c'est un livre tout ce qu'il faut
faire
chabal et même si une semaine plus tôt
il a reçu des pierres lors d'une visite
à mea sharim le maire fait profil bas
c'est vrai qu'il ya une petite partie de
la population
une minorité parmi les ultra orthodoxes
avec qui on a un petit problème
cette minorité se rebelle et participe à
des violences mais elle fait partie de
la ville on est obligés de les accepter
me
le maire ménage donc d'une certaine
manière les hommes en noir le contraire
serait politiquement délicat trop lourd
d'autant que certains d'entre eux ne se
contente pas de vouloir changer la ville
mea sharim le jour anniversaire de
l'indépendance d'israël quelques
centaines d'hommes en noir défilent la
frange la plus radicale
la plupart des ultras s'accommode de la
vie en israël mais eux rejettent pour
des raisons religieuses
l'existence même du pays une minorité
certes mais vous allez le voir très
active
c'est à aimer
[Applaudissements]
ultime provocation en fin de cortège des
enfants brûlent des drapeaux israéliens
et puis surprise ils en brandissant un
autre palestinien
le nom de cette mouvance des tours et
cartes a littéralement les gardiens de
la cité
leur chef le rabbin hirsch il vite au
coeur de méa sharim selon lui l'état
d'israël est un blasphème s'étaient
créés dans le talmud le livre sacré du
judaïsme
[Musique]
je vais vous montrer ce que dit le
talmud dieu a fait promettre aux juifs
de ne pas créer un état en allant à
l'encontre des autres nations sinon ils
deviendraient des animaux la proie des
chasseurs ce texte prouve qu'en ayant
créé l'état d'israël
le peuple juif se révoltent contre dieu
jeu va donc détruire cet état c'est ce
que dit la prophétie et nous pensons que
ce sera très bientôt
aujourd'hui le rabbin hirsch reçoit les
dirigeants de neturei karta des hommes
donc qui refuse tout lien avec le pays
aucun par exemple n'accepte la
nationalité israélienne tous possèdent
des passeports étrangers et il parle le
yiddish l'hébreu est proscrit comme
symbole du sionisme leur objectif vivre
en minorité dans un futur état
palestinien
nous refusons de profiter de l'argent de
l'état nous ne touchons pas l'assurance
maladie nous n'allons pas dans leur
école
nous n'allons pas alarmer et nous
n'allons pas voter aux élections en
général tant que l'on peut rester en
dehors de l'état nous le faisons
les neturei karta seraient entre 1000 et
3000 à vivre ainsi en marche de
jérusalem avec des ramifications aux
états unis et en europe
peu nombreux mais animé par une foi
indéfectible et n'ont qu'un but vivre
dans un état palestinien coûte que coûte
quitte à fraterniser avec les pires
ennemis d'israël avec ce cadeau nouveau
manifestons notre gratitude pour la
douceur et l'amour que vous exprimez
envers les juifs et l'humanité tout
entière
en septembre 2007 plusieurs membres de
neturei karta soutiennent publiquement
le président iranien ahmadinedjad
quelques mois après qu'il ait déclaré
vouloir rayer israël de la carte
il rencontre également ismaël haniyeh
premier ministre du hamas à gaza ou
encore dieudonné et lorsque celui ci est
accusé d'antisémitisme en france il
n'hésite pas à ceux ci ne pense qu'à
venir le soutenir à paris à comprendre
vous ne pensez pas que des leaders
politiques comme ahmadinejad ou les
membres du hamas profitent de vous pour
prétendre qu'ils ne sont pas antisémites
ne sont pas antisémites
il déteste seulement les sionistes et
ils ont de très bonnes raisons
cela n'a rien à voir il ne nous utilise
pas puisque nous sommes d'accord avec
des juifs contre israël voilà sans doute
l'un des plus beau paradoxe du proche
orient mais comme l'état hébreu reste
une démocratie il prospère quitte à
scier la branche sur laquelle ils vivent
au pied de l'hindu kuch peshawar la
capitale culturelle pachtoune
ici on ne boxe pas on préfère les
explosifs
c'est que les pachtouns vive entre deux
pays le pakistan et l'afghanistan
la légende affirme que les pachtouns
cultive de patients les armes et le
cinéma
chaque année peshawar produit une
trentaine de films et des centaines
d'heures de série télé un penchant que
les talibans ont proclamé à rames c'est
à dire péché car selon eux il pervertit
les valeurs du coran
[Musique]
depuis quelques mois une guerre sainte
est déclarée contre tous ceux qui
préfèrent les cinémas aux prières mais
y'a rien pêcher dans ses films c'est
juste des films d'action avec des
acteurs un contenu stoch et les menaces
sont mises à exécution de préférence le
vendredi le jour de la grande prière
récemment une voiture piégée a explosé
dans cinéma street la rue des cinémas
bilan 10 morts et 75 blessés depuis les
attentats se sont succédé avec des
centaines de victimes
aujourd'hui les salles ferment les unes
après les autres au grand bonheur des
talibans attentats sont un moyen pour
nous de faire comprendre que nous
n'acceptons plus le développement de
lieux de perversion comme les cinémas
cinéma street quelques semaines après
l'attentât
nous sommes retournés au tass vire mal
le palais des images un des cinémas
visés par les talibans les travaux de
reconstruction ne sont toujours pas
terminés et les employés vivent dans la
crainte des représailles
la police est encore venu nous prévenir
qu'il y avait un risque d'attentât
suicide aujourd'hui
le manager tient à nous faire rencontrer
son machiniste gravement blessé par
l'explosion
tu vas bien aujourd'hui
[Musique]
oui ça va on fait aller dans l'attentât
j'ai perdu l'usagé de mes jambes sur
celle ci il me manque tout une partie
dos et sur l'autre je n'ai plus aucune
sensation
j'ai perdu ma cheville mais j'ai de la
chance parce qu'il ya eu dix morts et
moi je n'ai été que blessé très vite le
ton monte
ici les talibans ne sont pas apprécié
ces gens là ce ne sont pas de vrais
musulmans que dieu les chasses du
pakistan c'est dans cette rue où se
concentrent les cinémas de la ville que
les talibans ont décidé de faire régner
leur loi
quelques mètres plus loin une autre
salle a également été prise pour cible
ici il y avait le plus vieux cinéma de
la ville mais il a été détruit par un
attentat
menacé de mort par les talibans les
propriétaires ont préféré vendre
du coup c'est un centre commercial qui
va s'élever sur ces décombres
la ville comptait 21 cinéma aujourd'hui
il ne reste plus qu'une dizaine
l'objectif des taliban et d'en finir
avec le commerce de ces films tous jugé
impur
les explosions ont touché tout le monde
même notre magasin cet été ils sont en
train de détruire tout le quartier
tout le monde a peur les talibans ne
supporte pas les films pachtoune
ils disent que ce sont des films x parce
qu'il montre des femmes qui travaillent
des infirmières des médecins et sages ne
supporte pas dans le cinéma pachtoune
les actrices en général tiennent un rôle
central est toujours bien en chair selon
les critères de beauté locaux
c'est pour elles que se battent les
hommes au final récompensés par des
danses torride mais les baisers sont
interdits et les scènes d'amour
pudiquement suggéré
[Musique]
nous avons voulu assister à un tournage
un rendez-vous nous a été donné dans un
village à une vingtaine de km de
peshawar
jusqu'au dernier moment l'adresse a été
tenue secrète vous êtes attendus car les
talibans ne s'en prennent pas qu'au
cinéma
il s'attaque aussi aux acteurs c'est
derrière les murs de cette maison à
l'abri des regards que se tourne un des
prochains films pachtoune
[Musique]
le réalisateur tarik jamal est l'un des
plus connus de la ville un des plus
menacées aussi
un tournage c'est comme une opération
secrète
vous savez si quelqu'un apprend que nous
sommes en train de travailler ici et
qu'ils viennent et qu'ils jettent une
grenade dans le jardin qui sera
responsable qui sera responsable pour
leur vie c'est pour ça qu'on travaille
cacher des acteurs qui continue
d'exercer leur métier
malgré des moyens dérisoires malgré la
peur et les pressions très dur pour les
fans il s'imagine les pires choses sur
les tournages conçoit chanteuse actrice
ou présentatrice ils me considèrent
comme des prostituées accueil comment
les islamistes justifie t'il une telle
violence contre le cinéma
début de réponse dans l'une des écoles
coraniques de peshawar c'est de là que
sont sortis de nombreux moudjahidine qui
ont combattu en afghanistan
[Musique]
l'imam nous accueille et nous fait
l'honneur d'une visite voici notre
professeur de loi coranique
pas question de sortie cinéma pour les
300 étudiants mais toutes les vidéos ne
leur sont pas interdites
on n'a pas le droit de voir des films où
il ya des femmes c'est considéré comme
un péché mais on peut regarder les
vidéos de moudjahidine et c'est sur ce
type de discours que s'appuient les
terroristes pour justifier les attentats
une rencontre a été organisée à la
sortie de peshawar
l'homme qui nous attend sur le toit se
présente comme porte parole d'un des
groupes les plus violents du pakistan le
tehrik-e-taliban pour eux tout ce qui
est contraire à la charia la loi
islamique doit être combattue et détruit
nous ne commettons des attentats que sur
les lieux de grande perversion comme les
cinémas
selon le prophète lorsque vous voulez
combattre un foyer de perversion vous
devez d'abord faire comprendre à ceux
qui pêchent la gravité de leurs actes
c'est ce que nous faisons à chaque fois
nous envoyons un message d'avertissement
nous nous expliquons quels sont les
péchés reprochés et les conséquences il
continue et s'ils ne veulent pas
comprendre le prophète nous autorise
alors à recourir à la force
ironie du sort c'est à quelques
centaines de mètres que se cache un
couple d'acteurs acquis les taliban ont
promis la mort
[Musique]
depuis la fin de leur carrière lui a
ouvert une épicerie et elle est devenue
couturière un groupe d'hommes a arrêté
dans la rue il montrait une vidéo sur
leur téléphone portable
ils m'ont dit que la même chose
m'arriverait si je n'arrêtais pas de
faire l'actrice sur l'écran on voyait un
homme en train de se faire décapiter
après quelqu'un du ouvrait le torse
alors qu'il avait les mains attachées
dans le dos qu'est ce qu'on pouvait
faire
du coup on est obligé de rester à la
maison on a ouvert une boutique et je
vends des bonbons aux enfants avant
l'arrivée des talibans dans la ville
nous étions heureux nous avions une vie
normale depuis qu'ils sont là on est
obligé de vivre comme ça la vie est
devenue un cauchemar
[Musique]